[Music]
michelle styles is off the market i
recently have been spending a lot of
time with someone that's very important
to me their name is steve flip during
last week selling sunset reunion
michelle confirmed the dating rumors and
now the reality star is opening up about
falling for her new partner who
identifies as non-binary i know that
some of you won't understand this or
agree with this but for me
it is about the person
it is about their heart and yes there's
that part of you that's like what you're
attracted to but for me i am attracted
to masculine energy and i don't really
care what the physical form is with g um
you know they identify as non-binary and
so their pronouns are they them and they
identify you know um on
both sides of male female
and so
that's one of those things
i personally find such a beautiful mix
and i think
you know it's probably why we did
connect on such a deep level
g-flip is the aussie singer who met
christelle on set of their steamy music
video get me out of here which drops
tomorrow they even got some new ink to
celebrate the occasion thanks to krishel
and according to people magazine the
happy couple already moved in together